we want to go live now to Secretary of
State Mike Pompeo he is actually
testifying on Capitol Hill right now it
is a budget hearing we are monitoring
that to see if he says anything about
that cancelled summit he was just
actually reading the letter from
President Trump to the North Korean
leader Face the Nation moderator
Margaret Brennan is also on Capitol Hill
this morning
Margaret I woke up this morning and I
saw what the North Korean officials said
in terms of warning of a nuclear nuclear
showdown calling the vice president of
the United States a political dummy this
White House have any other option than
to push back hard no you're right
rhetorically they kind of boxed
themselves in and then we're in turn
boxed in by the North Koreans remember
it was as you've already been talking
about the Libya model language at the
end of April that John Bolton the
national security adviser started
signaling that set off this chain of
very negative press communications
through their state-run media but you
also have to keep in mind what President
Trump let slip the other day which was
he thinks that the Chinese have started
to assert their own influence they are
the main patron of North Korea and that
is also marked a shift in taking a
harder position on the part of North
Korea in terms of their willingness to
negotiate I was here in Capitol Hill
with a top senator about to walk into
that Foreign Relations Committee hearing
with Mike Pompeo the Secretary of State
as they learned that this summit was off
and there had already been a lot of
conversation about whether the Secretary
of State and the National Security
Advisor were actually on the same page
here remember it was Pompeyo who has
been twice to North Korea there was some
talk he might have to personally go a
third time before that summit was to
happen this has been such an unusual
round of diplomacy this wasn't played
safe like you've seen in the past with
lower-level officials working it up to
the presidential level this was a Hail
Mary pass in many ways that many
Republicans and Democrats either
criticized heavily or credited the
president for being willing to take the
risk to meet face to face with Kim
jong-un but
was always the question of what truly
was North Korea willing to negotiate
this time because while the White House
argued they had North Korea in a
position of weakness economically
arguably North Korea has never been
stronger in terms of their negotiating
position because they have such a
nuclear arsenal so as you say nor that
rhetoric over the past few days for for
the vice president to have gone back and
referenced the Libya model in particular
was in many ways asking for this kind of
response from North Korea it's gotten
personal and perhaps some of that had to
do with that called off meeting if you
remember Mike Pence the vice president
was supposed to have with Kim jong-un's
sister around the time of the Olympics
you're right it has gotten very personal
thank you very much Margaret Brennan